les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de france 24 al despedirnos de
la primera parte de 2022 repasamos las
películas que hicieron volver al público
a las salas de cine y sin sorpresa
encontramos a las superproducciones
arriba de la taquilla los aviadores
víctor john maybury que lideran la
carrera con más de mil millones de
dólares de ingresos en todo el mundo la
apuesta a la ganó en gran medida al
actor tom cruise que pospuso el estreno
de la película varias veces durante la
familia para que pudiera entrenarse en
un cine y no en una plataforma
siguen después los universos llenos de
magia y efectos especiales con doctor
strange en el multiverso de la locura
jurassic word dominion y batman que
hasta ahora han recaudado entre 934 y
770 millones de dólares
y en quinta posición llegan las
graciosas criaturas de minions nace un
villano o la quinta entrega de la
franquicia superó los lanzamientos de
todas las otras producciones animadas ya
que solo se estrenó el 30 de junio
pero una de las grandes sorpresas de
esta primera mitad del año es el éxito
de todo en todas partes al mismo tiempo
de los daniels daniel juan y daniel
schneider es una comedia delirante en
inglés y en chino tan vertiginosa como
absurda que logró pasar del estatus de
cinta independiente de ciencia ficción
aunque no menos de la taquilla con más
de 95 millones de dólares de ingresos en
el mundo
un éxito que dejamos a una película
radicalmente diferente buena suerte leo
grande de la directora sophie hide emma
thompson estupenda como siempre diente
apreta a una viuda de 55 años que
contrata a un guapo trabajador sexual
para ayudarla a liberarse es una
película íntima delicada pero que nos
hace también reír con sus diálogos muy
inteligentes sobre el derecho al placer
veamos el trailer
[Música]
con espinas emperador que parece
suicidas
[Música]
a veces tengo
dejamos ahora las salas de cine para
viajar a las montañas del kirguistán en
asia donde se celebró del 21 al 23 de
julio el festival mundial de la moda
nómada creado en 2019 es un proyecto
único que glorifica a la civilización de
los pueblos nómadas ante un público
internacional se presentaron colecciones
de unos 40 diseñadores de países tan
diferentes como indonesia marruecos o
francia que jugaron a mezclar lo antiguo
con lo moderno en sus creaciones de
trajes
seguimos nuestro tour del mundo de la
actualidad artística en mexico con el
proyecto the wall el muro esta obra de
danza contemporánea explora la dicotomía
de celebrar las tres décadas de la caída
del muro de berlín en un momento donde
los flujos migratorios baten récords el
espectáculo dio inicio al festival
internacional de la danza danza plana
que ofrece eventos alrededor del baile
en ciudad de méxico hasta el primero de
agosto
en brasil familiares y amigos de las
víctimas del colapso de una represa del
correo de facebook se reunieron para
trazar los contornos de la pieza gigante
del artista francés taipei estas manos
entrelazadas se rinden homenaje a los
270 muertos y 4 desaparecidos que dejó
esta tragedia en 2019 una obra para
concienciar sobre los impactos de la
industria minera
y en colombia el país entero rinde
homenaje a una de sus figuras más
importantes de la música popular darío
gómez el rey del despecho fallece a los
71 años de un ataque del corazón el 26
de julio en medellín tanto su público
como sus familiares lo lloraron y
cantaron sus canciones para decirle
adiós
nos quedamos en el tema de la música
para hablar de dos artistas colombianos
que estrenaron colaboraciones con
colegas argentinos de valín se unió a la
rapero argentino en pleno ascenso trueno
en el tema 1 pasó una boda a sus
orígenes y a los barrios populares de
latinoamérica
mientras que el galardonado cantautor
camilo colaboró por primera vez con la
argentina nicole en la canción
naturaleza que anima a las personas a
celebrar sus propias peculiaridades y
excentricidades
[Música]
ellos tampoco habían colaborado juntos
antes la australiana toms de nadie que
el mundo descubrió con el tema de smokey
y en estadounidense michael moore
estrenaron cents el primer adelanto del
próximo disco de lara propio
[Música]
nos despedimos con la última canción de
taichi la estrella francesa del afro
love que se fue a angola para grabar el
videoclip de the face sin efectos la
historia de una relación tóxica que se
agota y llega a su final gracias a
ustedes por su confianza y cuídense
[Música]